blake shelton he's also going to be here
he just flew in from florida
where he performed at his new old red
bar and only et's cassie delaura caught
up with blake before he hit the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
what a way to kick off acm's weekend
where you are nominated
with gwen for nobody but you
[Music]
this is gwen's first hcm nomination what
does it mean to you to share this moment
with your
fiancee well i i texted her
actually uh this morning on the way here
i wish she was here with me
and i texted her that i can't believe
that
i get to be nominated for awards with my
best friend you know
and it was just one of those moments
it's like how do you get so blessed and
so lucky you know
but just 15 minutes after our blake
interview
came this emotional surprise
carly pearson lee bryce edged out blake
and gwen
winning music event of the year for i
hope you're happy now
[Music]
the category was announced ahead of
sunday's show on cbs
and blake joked to us about losing if we
don't win it's
we'll know it's rigged
[Laughter]
blake hit the stage last night in
orlando for the opening of his ole red
restaurant
it's filled with memorabilia including
these classic outfits
gwen and blake wore on the voice how is
it playing live music again
i'm really excited i'm just taking it
one step at a time
as for blake's acm performance if you're
calling bout
my heart it will honor his first number
one song
austin which was released 20 years ago
today
blake can hardly believe it first of all
i'm still alive
second of all that i'm still doing this
you know 20 years later